pretty much sums up how things have gone
for max of late in fact jeff it's been
so good over the last three games he's
shaved almost six full earned runs over
off of his season era now reynolds
banding with newman at first
and one out here's the 1-0 pitch and a
swing in the ground ball fair right up
the third base line past riley's attempt
it gets past the sidewall and into the
corner newman's waved around third the
relay will be cut off and it'll be a
double and an rbi for bryan reynolds and
the pirates start off leading one to
nothing gregory polanco the pitch
big curveball fly ball right uh cunhas
there he's got it and that retires the
side free throws 16 pitches pittsburgh
strikes first and the red hot braves
offense goes to work
not too shabby eras jumped up there a
little bit after that last start
been down to the twos
up till now but if you put it on the
edge to these guys
they're gonna hack
there you go
oh sharply hit takes a
tough little hop
but frazier handles it
marcel hitting 109 on breaking balls
this year yeah it's not like him
smoke the other way at a base hit for
ozuna to right center that's what we saw
a lot from marcel last year that's how
you hit 338. there you go well the way
that the braves are hitting the ball
right now the last thing you want to do
is extend an inning for a guy as hot as
austin riley has been you know that
austin reilly has the highest average in
major league baseball in the last 32
games
swing and a high fly ball belted left
center field that baby's deep then
baby's gone
son
a three run homer out of riley
his eighth of the year and it's 3-1
braves they've gone deep again versus
pittsburgh
to william contreras the braves young
catcher 235 with four home runs
swinging a miss
strikes out contreras second k
two down breed executes the bunt now
back to the top of the order and acuna
trying to add on to this 3-1 lead here
in a second
1-1
swinging a soft ground ball on the short
newman gloves and throws onto first for
the out and the inning is through so one
out single
and that's it
and reynolds works a two out walk
stallings bounced out his only time
nothing in one
broken bat roller ozzie was in the shift
he will make the play and flipped first
and freed has an easy third inning
freddie freeman will lead it off for
atlanta the braves lead three to one
he's probably the only brave that's been
frustrated in this series at the plate
there's a swing and a miss boy he struck
him out it and a slider down and then
he's been pitched very well in this
series i think so brubaker's had some
two out trouble here brave stay out of a
one two three inning they extend it for
austin reilly and again austin comes up
with two outs that's where he's really
thrived one to riley he hits one hard
out to right center field this one is
riding back to the wall this one is gone
austin riley
starting a house fire here in this
series
my goodness
that bounced off the top of the brick
wall and sprung right off into the seats
it's a two home run ball game
when you're going good you're going good
riley five pirates one
we talked at the beginning of the
broadcast how we'd like to see max fried
get the ball on the ground a little more
i think it's safe to say he's done that
that's going to be a big part of his
success
for eric gonzalez
and another ground ball riley spears
that one sets and fires a strike to
first
and one man out
last three starts he's only given up one
run
five innings six innings six innings
that's pretty fantastic a definite
difference since he changed mechanically
and just stayed back a little longer
on the ground into the shift and easy
play for ozzy there's another ground out
[Applause]
and a swing and a miss freed has a one
two three fourth inning that believe it
or not is his first strikeout in the
game he leads five to one ildemar vargas
the pitcher spotted then adam frazier
coming up for the buckos we are in the
fifth inning
and this one softly hit off the end of
the bat ozzie to his left tricky hop
funny spin made the play one out
two two count
it's on the ground freddy freeman's got
it he will lead max perfectly to the bag
and two up two down nine outs on the
ground for max and frazier's coming up
is this one on the ground towards second
the throw to first will be in plenty of
time easy hitting for max freight he's
through five with a 5-1 advantage
freddie hasn't joined the party yet
today he has struck out twice
in the air to center coming on reynolds
makes a great catch
in shallow center field
and when he dives for a ball
it's always like
necessary everything and how many times
does he come up with the catches he does
most times
stalling's the catch of the batter oh
for two two in the pitch
swung on line toward right field that
might get down for a hit on comes a cuny
and he makes a shoestring catch
racing in from right field good defense
in the inning by the braves three up and
three down
go the pirates
the good news for ozzy is both timings
got on base he's been able to jog hoe
because of this guy so what in the world
does brubacher throw riley now he's hit
a homer on the slider he had homer on
the fastball he try fastball down the
middle and see what happens that's my
guess swinging in a miss and like rock
said riley strikes out so maybe it's
dansby's turn here's the old wonder
swanson swung on hit in the air to left
field and pretty deep
back goes vargas he's on the track he
looks up it's gone
it was dansby's turn his eighth homer
rbis 18 and 19
7-1 atlanta
only 78 pitches for max frade he has
been in complete command
in the air to right and that's going to
get down in front of acuna so polanco
reached out and hooked that into right
field and that's the first pirates hit
since the first inning and their first
base runners since the third swaying and
a miss the bat goes flying off the
netting vargas
is retired two outs two on
in the air towards shallow center
heredia says he's got it and he does max
freed has been dazzling today he has
scattered just four hits a couple of
strikeouts but he has a commanding 7-1
lead
line toward right and arcogna got there
he was on a flat out sprint and reached
up at the last moment to snag that hard
hit ball what a play we should be
tipping our cap ronald that was
something wow is there nothing that man
can't do here's polanco final hope for
the pirates he has a seventh inning hit
in the air to center already turned the
wrong way but has plenty of room and the
braves have beaten the pirates
7-1 is your final